IQ scores are plummeting in the US and
throughout the west meanwhile at certain
wealthy high schools upwards of one in
three students says a learning
disability means he needs to take extra
time on the SAT congressional Democrats
try to make former pediatric
neurosurgeon and current HUD secretary
ben Carson look like an idiot CNN's
Allison camerota accidentally makes
Democrat presidential candidate Kamala
Harris look like an idiot and hippies
can now legally compost their dead in
the state of Washington we will ask the
question on everyone's mind
is everyone getting stupider I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the answer is yes by the way everyone is
getting stupider that's it that's our
show
good night see you tomorrow we we have a
crisis of intelligence happening not
just in the United States but around the
West we will examine why that is
happening and how we can try to fix it
before it's too late but first support
for the Michael Noel's ohcome from our
friends at rocket mortgage by Quicken
Loans finding the right house isn't easy
but finding the right mortgage can be we
talked yesterday about how Millennials
don't want to grow up a lot of them are
in buying houses this is a step into
adulthood and rocket mortgage is doing
more to help you understand the home
buying process so you can get exactly
what you need because it's not just a
mortgage it is your mortgage and they've
found a better way their team of
mortgage experts is obsessed with
finding a better way which means that
their number one goal is to make the
home buying process smoother for you
I know I've looked at a lot of homes
buying a home can be really miserable
rocket mortgages there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way what can loans has
helped millions of Americans achieve
their dream of home ownership and when
you are ready to purchase the home of
your dreams they can help you too
because when you work with them you get
more than just a loan because rocket
mortgage is more than just a lender get
started online right now take that step
into adulthood and make the whole
process a lot easier
rocket mortgage comm / Knowles canna
wles Equal Housing lender licensed in
all 50 states n MLS consumer access org
number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage simple as that
people are getting stupider in the US
and around the the other developed
nations how do we know this well one
because we have eyes so we open them and
we can see it happening around us we can
measure it to a certain degree as well
so for much of the 20th century IQ
intelligence quotient scores were
increasing they were increasing threat
most of the world and this bewildered a
lot of researchers because IQ you would
expect would be static IQ is just
supposed to be inherited it's not IQ
doesn't measure the facts that you've
learned throughout your life IQ measures
house more
you are so we were told that by the age
of 10 people's IQ is set its static you
inherit it from your parents it actually
turns out that environmental factors can
play a role in your IQ so over time the
IQ of whole populations can increase
it's more than just hereditary this rise
is called the Flynn effect this was
named after James Flynn who was the
first guy to bring this phenomenon to
the attention of a lot of psychologists
so this was going on for much of the
20th century everybody was getting
smarter now fast forward to the 21st
century you are seeing the exact reverse
phenomenon people are getting stupider
IQ scores are decreasing and you don't
need to take my word for it
Flynn himself admits this James Flynn
admits the IQ gains of the 20th century
have faltered so in its by the way it's
not just reversing everywhere uniformly
it's reversing specifically in the most
economically advanced nations the United
States being at the top of that heap so
why is I Q declining there have been a
few theories proposed some of them more
eugenicist and racist than others one
theory that is being proposed is that
people are getting stupider on average
because stupid people are having more
kids so the this is this was the plot
actually to the 2006 Mike judge comedy
film idiocracy the idea is that smart
people delay having children they have
fewer children and stupid people all
have a bunch of kids by the time they're
18 that's one theory
another theory and this one's even more
eugenicist is that because of massive
immigration over the last thirty years
you've got a bunch of people from the
undeveloped world coming into developed
countries and therefore the average IQ
is being reduced so the theory here is
that you flood your country with stupid
people and on average your nation gets
stupider again a little bit on the more
racially provocative side turns out
neither of those theories are true so a
20-18 study came out of Norway that shot
them down
it showed that IQ is not just dropping
across
all of society uniformly its or on
average it's dropping specifically
within individual families so within
over the course of generations within
the same family iq is dropping that
takes out the possibility that it's just
stupid people having more kids and it
takes out the possibility that you can
blame immigrants from poor countries for
the average intelligence going down so
why is it really happening well one
theory the theory that seems to me
pretty likely is the internet so now
because we have the sum total of human
knowledge allegedly in our pockets we
don't need to memorize anything we don't
need to really study anything I remember
I was taught this in school I was taught
you don't really need to learn these
facts and these historical dates and
these people who did certain things you
don't need to memorize that because you
can just look it up when you need it you
don't really need to figure out how to
do advanced calculus or or even basic
arithmetic because we have computers you
can just look it up you don't need to
memorize those things and so the end
goal of this would be to say just learn
broad narratives just learn the kind of
ideological narratives that we tell you
and the thing is you can't learn broad
trends really unless you have the data
that go into those trends otherwise
you're just taking somebody's word for
it so for instance if I said in the
United States race relations have
improved over the last 150 years 200
years you might say oh I don't believe
you Michael and say no I could I can
prove it because in 1860 we had slavery
in 1865
we had the abolition of slavery then we
had Jim Crow but then we got rid of Jim
Crow and then we had segregation laws
and we kept black people out of certain
neighborhoods then we got rid of those
laws then we elected a black president
in 2008 see I've got all these data
points and I can see the trend the races
are coming together in the United States
they'd say ok now plenty of students
could be told as they are in public
schools all around the country that
race relations haven't really improved
it's all a lie things are just as bad
today as they were a hundred years ago
and if you don't have all of those facts
you might have the broad trend but you
wouldn't know if that's true you'd be
ignorant and you wouldn't even know to
look it up you wouldn't even know to
google it because you you don't know
what you don't know Donald Rumsfeld when
he was Secretary of Defense ten years
ago he said there are known knowns known
unknowns and unknown unknowns so there
are things that you know that you know
that you know then there are things that
you know that you don't know
for instance I don't know much about the
reign of Charlemagne I know that
Charlemagne existed I know he was an
historical figure I just don't actually
know the specifics and then there are
certain things that you don't know that
you don't know increasingly that
category is expanding and so I think
that's a big part in why we're all
getting stupider there are other
theories as well a bunch of left wingers
are blaming it on global warming they're
saying that because of global warming
somehow food is getting less nutritious
and it's killing our brains and you know
the smog and the Sun monster and I of
course there's no evidence for any of
this really we we don't know for certain
we have a couple hunches and but the
effect does seem to be real I really
like this story for a couple reasons one
because it does cut against the premise
of progressivism what conservatives like
to point out is that history doesn't go
in a straight line sometimes things get
better sometimes things get worse
sometimes things get better in one place
but worse in another place history is
kind of like a big zigzag and the
individual actions of men and
communities and nations really matter
and what the progressives want to say is
old time bad modern time good old people
stupid modern people smart that's what
they like to tell us so this is why we
scoff at our own history why we want to
rename the Thomas Jefferson dinners
because we say oh that is a bad old guy
he owns slaves he's bad
we were good because we're modern we
live in the in the modern age which is
much better so this obviously cuts
against that
we are not smarter than our forebears at
least our forebears 20 years ago they
had a higher average intelligence than
we do the other reason I like this story
is I don't put a whole lot of stock in
IQ I I do put stock into certain
standardized tests like the SAT the SAT
is a standardized test that tests
something really specific which is
whether students are ready for college
you get a score and that score reflects
a student's readiness to go to college
the graduate school tests tests that the
LSAT tests your readiness for law school
the GRE your readiness for graduate
school the IQ test isn't like that the
IQ test purports to test the generalized
total complete intelligence of somebody
which I don't really think you can do
and I I know people with very high IQs I
know people with very low IQs and I
don't see a huge correlation between
success some of the most successful
people I know have significantly lower
IQs according to tests then then people
who have higher test scores and haven't
done as well in life now we are still
getting stupider and this is true not
just on these generalized tests it's
true even on the specific tests like the
SAT speaking of which now at wealthy
schools huge numbers of students are
pretending to be learning disabled in
order to get extra time on the SAT we
talked about the SAT just the other day
because the SAT is now adding an
adversity score so they're
unstandardized the standardized test
they're now pretending not just to
measure a student's verbal skills or
math skills but also to measure the
suffering that student has undergone so
the SAT is in trouble to begin with
now we find out students at wealthy
schools or all pretending to have
learning disabilities to cheat to get
extra time on the test at Scarsdale High
School in New York which is right near
where I grew up one in five students at
that school has a learning disability
20% one of the wealthiest high schools
in the nation I know a lot of kids from
Scarsdale high school I had a college
roommate from Scarsdale high school 20%
of those kids do not have learning
disabilities at Weston High School in
Connecticut that number is one
for have a learning disability at Newton
North High School outside of Boston a
very wealthy high school one in three
does anybody really believe the 33% of
students that these wealthy schools have
learning disabilities no it would
explain the IQ question or would we
explain why these numbers are getting
jumbled but no it's because they're
cheating but the very fact that they're
cheating on these tests reflects a
cultural problem that does help to
explain why we're getting stupider we'll
get to it in a second and we'll get to
stupid politicians but first what's one
thing that is really stupid is carrying
around revolving debt if you're not
paying off your card every month and you
could be paying thousands of dollars in
interest every year that you don't have
to do that it is really stupid to pay
super high interest rates on revolving
debt with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt and/or pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since 2007 Lending Club has
helped millions of people regain control
of their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans don't be
stupid
no trips to the bank no high interest
credit cards don't pour your money away
I've seen too many friends of mine do
this they're just wasting money on high
interest credit cards right now do it if
you have revolving debt Kota Lending
Club com tell them about yourself how
much you want to borrow pick the terms
that are right for you and if you're
approved your loan is automatically
deposited into your bank account in as
little as a few days we all need a
little extra money sometimes things
happen that we don't expect the roof
starts leaking or whatever make sure you
borrow the right way Lending Club is the
number one peer-to-peer lending platform
with over 35 billion dollars in loans
issued go to Lending Club comm slash
Knowles Keo wles check your eight
minutes borrow up to 40 G's that is
$40,000 Lending Club comm slash Knowles
canna wles
Lending Club comm / Knowles all loans
made by Webb bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender so do we really think
that a third of students at really rich
high schools have learning disabilities
no these are obviously fake diagnoses
that are caused by a few factors one
caused by a culture that values of
victim
/ accomplishment the SAT used to be very
simple you go into a room there's a
teacher they time it you have to finish
the test in the amount of time you were
always right up against the wall it's a
it's a it is a tough time limit and you
finish the test and you're done very
simple very standardized now you have a
culture that doesn't value that real
accomplishment nearly as much as it
values victimhood
ironically victimhood has become a
privilege if you can pass yourself off
as a victim as some aggrieved group
someone with a learning disability even
if you don't have one then you get the
privilege of extra time on the tests and
you get to cheat and you get an unfair
advantage over all of your classmates so
it's it's a bad thing in our society
that students would do this that
students would be willing to cheat on
these exams but it's even worse that
their parents are letting them do it
their parents are encouraging them if
the kid is gonna cheat kids are always
going to cheat on tests that's that's
been true forever and it's always going
to be true parents and teachers are
supposed to come in and say no you can't
do that Johnny you need to take the test
you need to study you need to be able to
take it in the right amount of time you
don't have dyslexia Johnny you just
don't want to study and the parents
aren't doing that now the parents are
encouraging their kids to cheat they're
losing their scruples they're losing
their moral foundation and why because
this is being caused by a culture that
values college degrees over education
itself right we talked yesterday about
the Millennials the Millennials are
doing awful on every measure they're
poor they have a ton of debt they don't
have they don't get married they don't
have kids they don't have houses the one
area where they're allegedly doing well
is education because they all have a lot
of fancy college degrees except they
don't know that much when you actually
test their intelligence when you
actually test their knowledge they score
worse than other generations we talked
about all the time how the left likes
the appearance of the thing but not the
essence of the thing they like the
appearance but not the reality so they
want to eat vegan bacon they want to
drink a decaf coffee very bad idea in
the long run you
you can get a fancy degree but if it if
it doesn't actually reflect what you're
learning that's gonna hurt you and your
society in the long term according to
market watch 9 out of 10 new jobs go to
college graduates now why is that in
part it's because so many more people
are going to college but does that
really reflect a student's education
does that really reflect what a student
knows know as the edge I mean we've got
a lot of studies of this we know that
students are learning less than they
have in the past we know that in some
cases students are graduating from
college knowing less than they knew
going into college so as the educational
value of a college degree plummets the
social value of a college degree
skyrockets it's a credential that allows
you into a certain class and and that's
being reflected in our whole society we
have become a society that cheats on the
test it's not just these kids at a high
school in Massachusetts or in Scarsdale
New York we as a society cheat on the
test we just get shuffled along from
grade to grade from year to year without
actually doing the things that all of
that shuffling used to signify when you
graduated from high school that used to
mean something now it means much less
and now actually we've gotten so stupid
we can't even recognize the difference
between real intelligence and bloviating
and this has never been clearer than in
congressional testimony yesterday you
had congressional Democrats interviewing
Ben Carson the former with the current
Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development former presidential
candidate and former pediatric
neurosurgeon one of the smartest guys in
this entire country ben Carson was the
first guy to separate conjoined twins
conjoined at the head this guy is super
duper sharp and you've got these
congressional Democrats interviewing him
and the videos went all around the
internet trying to portray the Democrats
is really smart and Ben Carson is an
idiot how did they do it because the
video was pretty effective here's how
you two get back to me if you don't mind
to explain the disparity in REO rates do
you know what an REO is and Aurea are
not an Oreo an REO our real estate
what's the O stand for the organization
owned real estate owned that's what
happens when a property goes to
foreclosure we call it an REO oh good
you got him you got him
first of all I love Ben Carson's answer
here they're they're trying to make fun
of him for this answer but he's
obviously joking because she sets it up
it this is the classic example of a
gotcha question we're talking about
Housing and Urban Development she goes
in and she finds this really specific
jargony term and she doesn't ask him a
question about it notice the way she
phrases it she starts to say I want to
ask you about re OHS but then she
doesn't ask him a question about Oreos
she just says do you know what an Oreo
is ben Carson so thanks for coming here
do you know what the capital of Thailand
is gogo ha ha you don't you're an idiot
yeah yeah hello secretary Carson thank
you so much for being here what number
am I thinking of idiot you can't even
guess it can you she's she's asking him
to use to define this jargon for her the
whole thing is set up to make him look
ignorant and to make him look stupid and
he is having none of it because a ben
Carson is much much more intelligent
than this woman Katey Porter Democrat
congresswoman Sohee she's there he says
do you know what an Oreo is you you're
asking me about Oreos during
congressional testimony you want you
know not Oreos or yos I don't know it's
some stupid jargon that has to do with
real estate well yes it does have to do
with real estate but do you do you know
what the.oh is she even presses him on
that letter no why don't you tell me
tell me what the O is it's it's owned ha
ha see I've got you how dumb you are but
who cares
who cares what the term is what are you
asking about what what is your question
as it relates to housing and urban
development as it relates to poor
families in public housing
as it relates to the running of that
government agency it's just a way for
this woman to try to get on TV and to
grandstand and it worked but for the
people who are going around trying to
say that this is evidence that she's
really smart and ben Carson is really
stupid you could do that to anybody
about anything just ask even if it's in
their own field
people are saying Ben Carson should have
known this acronym because he's the head
of HUD they're resilient acronyms in the
government they're resilient jargony
terms I am certain that if I were
interviewing Katie Porter and I looked
through enough House bills that have
been passed just in this session I could
stump her on some some acronym it
doesn't tell you anything about the
actual intelligence of the person her
colleague Ayanna Presley tried to do the
exact same thing to Carson it was even
more egregious when she did it do you
believe the substandard public housing
conditions pose a risk to tenants
physical mental and emotional health you
already know the answer to that yes or
no you know the answer yes or no I know
the answer do you know the answer yes or
no reclaiming my time you don't get to
do that the time belongs to the
gentlelady
would you like your grandmother live in
public housing you know her would you
let your grandmother live in public
housing yes or no you know very wonder
you're watching at your helm would you
allow your grandmother to live in public
housing under these conditions would be
very nice if if you would stop I love
Ben Carson so much because he is having
none of it
she asks look Ben Carson has made very
clear that public housing is is really
awful and really dangerous and he wants
to curtail it and and stop it from
spreading and why is this the case
because he grew up in horrible
conditions and he is so thankful he says
that his mother who had him when she was
13 or something
kept him out of public housing because
of how dangerous it was so he says you
know the answer to that question and she
keeps pushing and she's getting angry
and Ben Carson remains
/ calm and this again people make fun of
him for this they say why is Ben Carson
so calm he's sleepy the reason is that
Ben Carson wasn't always calm ben Carson
was a real tough guy he was a maniac
when he was younger he was getting into
fights hitting people with baseball bats
he stabbed one of his friends when he
was 14 this guy grew up in horrific
conditions he writes about it he says
this was in one of his memoirs he says
there was pretty horrendous violence
gangs broken glass and boarded up
windows and doors murders I had two
cousins who were killed I remember as a
nine-year-old sitting on the ghetto
stairs looking to the building across
the street out of which all the windows
had been broken and there was a sunbeam
shining through and it made me think
about my future and I remember thinking
I probably won't make it to 25 that's
that's what he grew up in that guy knows
something about public housing that guy
knows something about poverty in America
that guy knows something about his job
and he's highly intelligent but these
these silly frivolous Congress women are
trying to make him look stupid and
people who are getting Dumber by the day
that overall in our society can't tell
the difference
Ayana presley is nobody she her her jobs
before she became a congresswoman was
she was a community organizer so
practically unemployed and she was a
model like model for photographs for
Planned Parenthood that was so that's
what she did with her life a Ben Carson
fought his way out of the ghetto
well his cousins were being killed and
their gangs all around him
fights his way out of the ghetto and
goes on to graduates from Yale I think
he went to Johns Hopkins and then he
becomes one of the leading neurosurgeons
in the world that guy much more
intelligent also by the way even on the
point of hud he's been a pretty good HUD
secretary HUD probably shouldn't even
exist as a department in the federal
government it was a product of the Great
Society it was one of these LBJ poverty
programs that has often hurt people that
it
intended to help and he's been pretty
good there first of all the less he does
at that department the better and he has
deregulated he has cut various program
budgets he has empowered local housing
authorities in particular to impose more
stringent work requirements on those who
were receiving government benefits he's
done a pretty good job there
if these people actually wanted to ask
him a question and learn something about
what he's doing do their oversight job
in Congress they could have asked him a
serious question about HUD they didn't
do that they're just trying to make him
look stupid and we are not even able to
understand the difference between those
things now there's another even better
video of a politician accidentally
looking stupid that was going around CNN
we'll get to that in a second then we'll
talk about how a presidential candidate
for the Democrats and the governor of
Washington is allowing hippies to
compost they're dead and I think come to
the final answer on why we're getting
dimmer and Dumber as a society but first
you've got to go to daily wire.com ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get them out wall show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag you get to
ask questions backstage you get another
Kingdom and you get this oh that's good
that tastes like Oreos that tastes
that's got that delicious Oreo taste as
the left screams and yells and cries go
to Daley wire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
so you've got those videos of ben Carson
and you've got all of these people going
around saying see he shouldn't be in the
government see he's stupid see how much
smarter the Democrats are there's
another former presidential candidate
who has explained why that is not a
measure of intelligence and it's one of
the all-time great presidential
candidates Herman Cain who put this very
well in 2012 are you ready for the
gotcha questions they're coming from the
media and others on foreign policy who's
the president of you Becca Snell you
know all of this stuff it's coming yes
and how are you dealing with that I'm
ready for the gotcha questions and they
are already starting to come and when
they asked me who's the president of you
Becky Becky Becky Becky Stan Stan I'm
gonna say you know I don't know do you
know and then I'm gonna say how's that
gonna create one job I want to focus on
the top priorities of this country
that's what leaders do absolutely
fabulous answer by the way Herman Cain
another very serious guy that everybody
tried to make fun of Herman Cain was the
CEO of a major pizza company and he was
on the Federal Reserve Board I think in
Kansas City or something like that
there's a very serious man and he gives
a good answer
anybody can ask a gotcha question you
can ask it of anybody and you can always
get your zing in and you can always get
a viral video clip that does not measure
intelligence there's another video
though on the Democrat side over at CNN
which it does if it doesn't tell you
something about this candidate's
intelligence it does tell you something
about her absolute failure to be able to
run seriously as a presidential
candidate CNN's Allison Camerata
gave the opposite of a gotcha question
to Kamala Harris the if we're talking
about Oreo and the chairman and
president of who's Becky Becky Stan Stan
Stan if that's the gotcha question this
is the polar opposite of that and yet
Kamala Harris couldn't even answer a
simple question about naming one song by
her allegedly favorite musical artist we
have a little fun kicker
that we'd like to do with all of the
presidential candidates that come on
it's called candidate mixtape that was
the musical sting for it and we'd like
to talk a lot about music here on this
program so what is your favorite musical
genre oh I mean um hip-hop and reggae
and jazz those are those are some of my
face okay do you have a favorite band or
a favorite musician I'd say one of my
favorites is Bob Marley good choice you
can't go wrong with that that's a
crowd-pleaser on your mixtape what would
be like your favorite three songs oh
okay let's see
I read the Franklin anything of read the
Franklin I would say Bob Marley and then
I don't know I love cardi B as she says
[Laughter]
those are great thank you for playing
along
oh gosh first of all Aretha Franklin is
not a song Bob Marley also not a song
and cardi B not a song those are people
there people that Kamala Harris is
obviously unfamiliar with and she's just
saying she likes them to try to appeal
to certain demographic groups but this
is so not a gotcha question that Kamala
Harris launched her campaign you'll
remember this her presidential campaign
launched on a mood mix where she talked
about all the songs she's listening to
and how they get her in the mood to run
for president and she named Aretha
Franklin she she said one of her
favorite songs was young gifted and
black and one thing and thread this
whole video throughout Camille Harris's
whole campaign is she's so clumsy about
how she's trying to appeal to identity
politics so she names that song young
gifted and black and she said she always
loved listening to that song when she
was young and what she's obviously
trying to tell you is that she was young
gifted and black and so you're supposed
to like that
she doesn't talk ever about her actual
career which is as a
Secutor she doesn't talk about that
because that she thinks that will hurt
her in the Democrat primary she talks ad
nauseam about anything in her past that
can be related to race or sexual
politics so she's always talking about
how she's of Jamaican descent she's
always talking about how she loves
traditionally ethnic musical genres so
she loves reggae she loves this she
loves that but then when you push her
just even one question in on what she
likes about those genres she can't name
a single song when she gets that
question what are your favourite genres
you can just see going through her mind
she goes okay what which musical genres
are going to most appeal to racial and
identity politics I'm a reggae okay
that's good hip hop that's good jazz
okay those are my answers and you can
see it on her face you can hear it in
her voice how awkward she feels saying
those things and then you can almost
hear her say please don't ask me
anything else
Allison cammarata asks will her your
favorite musicians because I'm Bob
Marley yeah I've heard that name before
Bob Marley there's okay great
name any Bob Marley song ever and she
draws a blank say no woman no cry' say
any Bob Marley is a very popular
musician but probably Kamala Harris
doesn't listen to those musicians a lot
she says she likes hip-hop and then she
was asked she said when did you listen
to hip-hop she said oh when I was in
college I was always smoking joints and
listening to Snoop Dogg and all the time
and then you google that for five
seconds and you realize Snoop Dogg
didn't release his debut song until
years and years after Kamala Harris
graduated from college just a lie she's
just probably here's what Kamala Harris
listens to because she's a serious woman
who is a powerhouse in politics and has
had a serious career she probably
doesn't listen to that much music she's
probably just a very busy lawyer who
doesn't sit around and listen to music
she's probably never smoked pot before
when she does listen to music
she probably listens to Bach or Brahms
or something because she's fairly
educated and she exists in very elite
tiers of society where the
what people listen to but she doesn't
think she can say that on TV so she has
to pretend that she's a member of the
choom gang puffing away on blunts
listening to Bob Marley or something I
am genuinely shocked at how bad that
woman is at running for president but
it's not the same as Ben Carson's video
ben Carson was asked a gotcha question
Kamala Harris was asked a total softball
question that she had already talked
about multiple times she couldn't do it
she couldn't fill it in she she wasn't
being accident portrayed as stupid she
was revealing herself at least as
unprepared and bad at running for
president but I think that is not the
stupidest gaffe of any 20/20
presidential candidate that honor goes
to jay Inslee the governor of Washington
he's the presidential candidate whose
logo looks like a cd-rom from the 1990s
he gets the award because he just signed
into law the nation's first bill that
will allow hippies to throw their dead
in the backyard and let them rot he
signed the first bill to allow people to
compost their dead it's called the
recompose program get it like repose but
compost recompose recompose this is in
in the hill recompose would be similar
to a crematorium but it uses a longer
and less carbon-intensive means of
organic Reduction commonly known as
composting so what that means is it's
similar to a crematorium in that it's
something that happens to dead bodies
but it's less carbon-intensive meaning
they don't like the bodies on fire
they just throw them in the backyard and
let them rot they go on it says the
process uses woodchips straw and other
materials and takes about four weeks it
is similar to livestock composting which
farmers use to turn animals into
odorless soil
yikes
first of all credit goes to jay Inslee
we've talked a lot about how
environmentalism is a top issue in the
2020 Democrat primary the green New Deal
has become the
biggest issue and if this is turning
into an environmentalist primary jay
Inslee is really turning this up to 11
jay Inslee is throwing dead human bodies
into the backyard and letting them
compost like dead cows for the
environment or something I mean it's
hard to beat that so credit on him for
turning the wacko up to 11 this story in
particular brings us right back to how
we are all getting much stupider as a
civilization this gets to one of the
basic behaviors of civilized society we
bury our dead why do we bury our dead
before we start letting people throw
granny into the backyard and let her rot
why do we bury our dead I think it's
becoming popular in this culture to say
we shouldn't bury our dead we can
cremate them or we can throw them into
the backyard or throw them out in the
water or something can you answer why we
bury our dead because it's not just some
social construct it's not just something
we decided to do a few hundred years ago
burial of the dead goes all the way back
to prehistory the Neanderthals buried
their dead non-human ancestral relatives
buried their dead this has been around a
long time why on a cultural level it's
because we have a relationship with our
dead more broadly we have a relationship
with our past leftist politicians want
to erase the relationship we have with
our past they want to tear down murals
and monuments and statues and rename
buildings and rename towns but we have a
relationship to our past not just our
national past but our family past we
like to have a gravestone where we can
go and visit the remains of our dead
relatives we have that relationship you
go and you pray or you go and you
remember it brings you back to a certain
memory of your past on a religious level
we bury our dead because at least in
Christianity and in the Christian West
we expect the resurrection of the body
this is what Christians say in the
Nicene Creed we look for
word to the resurrection of the body in
the life of the world to come when
Christ was crucified he was put into a
tomb and then he was bodily resurrected
he resurrected not just in some
spiritual sense but physically as well
and so we bury our dead because we look
forward to not just life in heaven but
the resurrection of the body in the
glorified body whatever that means
that's the religious reason on an
ethical and political level why do we
bury our dead because we respect
humanity we respect human beings simply
for being human beings we don't want
animals knowing at Granny's body in the
backyard we don't want to feed old
granny to the Coyotes we respect human
beings even after death this is why it's
a crime to desecrate bodies to
improperly handled dead bodies we offer
them a certain respect now however we
are losing that respect for Humanity
we are literally killing our own
children through abortion we are killing
our elderly through assisted suicide
which they call euthanasia but we're
kids sometimes we're killing them
against their will there was a big case
in the Netherlands where a woman said
please don't kill me I don't want to
drink the poison and her family held her
down in the doctor pool poured the
poison down her throat we are killing
our sick people who are ill even if
they're young to assisted suicide we're
killing those who have mental
deficiencies through abortion
we are losing respect for Humanity as
they are humans one of the arguments for
this law to compost the dead was well we
do it to cattle why shouldn't we do it
to humans in the old days we would have
said because humans matter more than
cattle now however we don't say that we
say yeah it's good point we're just
animals we're no different than a bug or
a snail or a dog or a cow but those are
the reasons that we bury our dead we're
obviously getting stupider we can see it
on the tests we can see it when Camilla
Harris goes on CNN we can see it in
these stupid laws that are being passed
like allowing us to
have dogs eat granny but as we get
stupider this is affecting our politics
as we forget our past it's getting worse
so we're getting stupider it's that line
we keep talking about from Ernest
Hemingway he's describing bankruptcies
says how do you go bankrupt gradually
then suddenly how do you get stupider
gradually then suddenly as you get
stupid or you get stupider as you forget
your past you really start to forget
your past you discard even more
traditions more quickly you sever that
connection to your civilization even
more greatly this is what the make
America great again slogan is all about
make America great again is it's about a
real sense that we've lost something
it's a process that it that is speeding
up and and it does threaten our
civilization I don't think we're all
gonna start walking around and become
total nincompoops who can't spell our
own names but we are socially becoming
stupider as well and before we go just
one story that I guess it's offers a
little bit of hope in this is it sums up
this this neglect of our past this
forgetting of our past and this hatred
of our past
Steve minutiae over a Treasury just
announced that Harriet Tubman will not
be going on the twenty dollar bill
during the Obama administration they
announced Harriet Tubman was going to
replace Alexander Hamilton on the $10
bill and this was widely criticized even
among left wingers this was widely
criticized because of the popularity of
the musical Hamilton so young liberal
people like Hamilton now so they said
okay we're not gonna replace Alexander
Hamilton will replace Andrew Jackson
that awful terrible founder of the
Democrat Party we're gonna replace
Andrew Jackson with Harriet Tubman and
everyone said this was a great idea and
Andrew Jackson for most of our nation's
history has been considered a very very
good president and in recent years he
has been portrayed by the revisionist
left as this genocide 'el maniac and
he's been accused of crimes he didn't
commit and he has been smeared as saying
things that he never said but the result
of all of this rewriting
history has come out that people on both
both sides of the aisle hate Andrew
Jackson and it's totally unfair and I'm
very glad that Harriet Tubman isn't
replacing him on the $20 bill I like
Harriet Tubman very much I'm a huge fan
of gun-toting Republicans but if they
want to give her some denomination they
can give her a denomination that's make
a three dollar bill or something but you
shouldn't erase Andrew Jackson from
history which is what people are trying
to do because Andrew Jackson was pretty
great Andrew Jackson was a hero it was a
literally a hero he was the hero of New
Orleans in the war of 1812 so he's a
military hero saves the United States he
as president threatened to invade South
Carolina if South Carolina seceded the
first time South Carolina wanted to cede
from the Union was in 1828 he threatened
to go in there kept the Union together
he settled a most favored nation treaty
with the British just pretty impressive
since he's one of the toughest hombres
fighting the British in the war of 1812
and then he comes in and secures that
most favored nation treaty he recognized
the Republic of Texas so he brings to
the Texas closer to the United States he
did a lot of good things he had a lot of
accomplishments the question to ask when
you want to remove Andrew Jackson from
the $20 bill is why did they put him on
the $20 bill to begin with what the
revisionists will tell you is because
America was a terrible awful place in
the past and everyone was stupid and
they really liked him because of how
evil he was that's not sufficient you
know that isn't true Andrew Jackson's
vices which are legitimate I mean he's
an imperfect guy like everybody and
great men tend to have great
imperfections his vices have been vastly
exaggerated and his many many virtues
and accomplishments have been totally
ignored by history people aren't
learning were severing our connection to
the past and we're getting dumber the
thing that he gets dinged on all the
time and they say it's the reason we
need to erase him from history is Indian
Removal because he provided over
presided over the removal of some
Indians from the southeast of the United
States this whole period of Indian
Removal has been totally misrepresented
when you say Andrew Jackson
to a left-winger and a revisionist the
first thing they're gonna say is the
Trail of Tears Andrew Jackson he caused
the Trail of Tears on which the Indians
were removed he didn't he wasn't even
president during the Trail of Tears the
Trail of Tears was enforced by his
successor Martin Van Buren as with
everything in history the true story is
much more interesting and much more
complicated the way that Indian Removal
happened was that the United States
purchased tribal land in exchange for
land to the west that were outside of
state borders so you had this real
political problem which is you had whole
Indian nations inside relatively newly
formed States in the relatively newly
formed United States did anybody really
think that the United States was going
to develop and permit these relatively
large nations independent nations to
exist within their boundaries of course
not that would not be able to happen the
United States could not develop that way
if you were president you would have
removed the Indians too you would have
secured treaties to do it which is what
he did
so the early treaties stipulated the
tribes could either move west or
surrender their sovereignty and obey the
state laws so there was either or one of
the first tribes to move her the
Chickasaw the Chickasaw moved with
relatively little trouble so they
secured this treaty and the way to
Chickasaw moved is they got a sum of
money and they were able to pay for much
of their own removal so there was
tragedy along the way but relatively
little relatively little famine
relatively little death they quickly
agreed they agreed to favourable
traditions they did it that was a an act
of pretty brilliant diplomacy then the
Choctaw were a little tougher because
the Chiefs of that nation were bribed
they also came to a treaty but at pretty
unfavorable terms they moved during the
winter of 1831 1832 there was a lot more
misery on that roof then you get the
Seminoles the Seminoles agreed to move
they signed a treaty the Treaty of
Paynes landing but then they refused to
move reneged on the treaty this launched
the Second Seminole War this happened to
other tribes as well in the case of the
Cherokees
this is what people think that they
remember in history that case made it to
the Supreme Court and it goes all the
way up to the Supreme Court and the line
that everybody remembers is after Chief
Justice John Marshall made his decision
Andrew Jackson said John Marshall has
made his decision now let him enforce it
this was seen as a tyrannical move to
steal power and upset the balance of
powers in our government the trouble
with that line which everyone knows
Andrew Jackson said is he never said it
there is no evidence that he ever said
it the line comes to us from horace
greeley who said that he heard it from
another guy who said that he heard it
from Andrew Jackson the way that we know
Andrew Jackson almost certainly didn't
say that is there was nothing about the
Supreme Court decision to enforce so the
sentence itself doesn't make any sense
how did this play out eventually the
Cherokees signed a treaty but then some
rejected that treaty because they said
that the Chiefs who signed it were not
legitimate leaders of the tribe and this
led to the Trail of Tears
in 1938 which I don't mean to underplay
it the Trail of Tears was horrific the
particulars of lots of Indian Removal
was horrific
however again that wasn't Andrew Jackson
Martin Van Buren was the president
Jackson didn't preside over that if you
want to remove Martin Van Buren from the
oh yeah he's not on any money okay that
fine I guess
Van Buren was not a great president but
Andrew Jackson actually was a pretty
great figure in American history and as
the culture gets stupider I think the
key thing one of the the key symptoms of
it is we think we're getting smarter we
think we have fancy college degrees we
think the Millennials are the smartest
best educated generation ever this is a
key among stupid people stupid people
think they're smart smart people know
that they're not smart Socrates famously
said I all that I know is that I know
nothing that's a key and so when you as
this 2020 race goes on as the the
political battle heats up you're gonna
have a lot of people trying to convince
you of how smart they are and the more
they protest about it
I think the clearer it is that those IQ
scores are right those SAT scores are
right the culture unfortunately getting
dumber and dumber that's our show we got
more to get to we'll do it tomorrow come
on back
I'm Michael Knowles's as the Michael
NOLA I'll see you tomorrow
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka watts and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show the Left moves to
embrace abortion as a moral good and
they let the homeless run wild in major
cities around the United States that's
today on the Ben Shapiro show